السودان ساكنين في عنبر واحد ما بنعرف
نجيسه شنو
كلنا كمان بيهجمعنا الكعكه ده تجمعنا
القوات المسلحه
للجيش السوداني لقواته بان لا فرق بين
جندي واخر بسبب قبيلته او ولايته ظهرت
بصوره المفاجئه وفي العلم مجموعه عسكريه
مكونه من ضباط متقاعدين ومجموعات قبليه
اطلقوا على انفسهم قوات كيان الوطن هدفهم
ان يصبحوا قوه موازيه للولايات التي لم
تكون فصائل مسلحه
تجمع عسكري في المقام الاول عسكري عندنا
قوات اخواننا لعمل توازن
الولايات التي كونت لها مجموعات مقاتله
وقعدت بها او تمكنت بها من الاستيلاء على
مقاعد ثابته في الوزاره
حمل السلاح عبر مؤتمر صحفي وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم بلو على بعد كيلو مترات من رئاسه
الجيش
اكشف المعلومات التي حصلت عليها العربيه
انهم 16 ضابطا متقاعدا بينهم سته من
المنتمين للتنظيم الاسلامي اما الاعداء
والضخمه التي تحدث عنها فهي مجموعات قبليه
ومناطقيه ترى انها مهمشه وايضا حركات
متمرده لم تجد حظها من السلطه والثروه
احزاب السياسيه معارضه للمكون العسكري
رفضت هذه الخطوات
[موسيقى]
لقوات ايا كان اسمها فهذا عمل مرفوض لا
نؤيده ولا نقبله
رغم ان دلاله الشخصيات وتوقيت التدشير
خلاف للمعهود ورغم خطوره الفكره واعتقال
من طبقوها الا ان محللين وخبراء عسكريين
قللوا من اهميتها
الامن الوطني
وبالتالي تنتهي هذه
الحدوته في تاريخ السودان
عشرات من الحركات المسلحه في عدد من
الولايات السودانيه استقود بالقبيله
والسلاح تحت مسمى التهميش فهل تعقد هذه
المحاكاه من اخرين المشهد السياسي والامني
المتازم لن يعقوب العربيه الخرطوم